[Applause]
a sight seldom seen in Beijing hundreds
of people on the streets voicing their
Fury at China's stringent zero covered
policy a rare show of public anger
against the leadership
in Shanghai the country's biggest city
police arrested for testers dragging
them away placing them on buses
the night before crowds of people were
shouting down with a Communist party
down with Xi Jinping
this latest outpouring of anger comes
after 10 people were killed in a fire at
an apartment Block in arumchi social
media users blamed a lockdown in the
xinjiang region for hindering rescue
efforts an ongoing measure in China's
zero covert policy that's fueling wider
unrest even as covet cases surge it is
definitely unusual that you have so many
different cities all across the chart
all across China demonstrating right now
you have students who are protesting you
have workers who have been protesting
and this is quite unusual to see this
all over China at this at this point in
time I think one of the main questions
will be now what will happen in the days
to come how will the Chinese leadership
react to this right now we have a lot of
going on in Chinese social media but we
can expect to have a harsh response on
the ability to communicate all those
pictures via social media but also on
the streets itself
vigils have been held at universities
across China and in shanghai's wollam
Chi Road a street named after the city
of arunshi in memory of the victims of
the fire
in the capital protesters sang while
holding up blank pieces of paper a
symbolic protest against censorship
borrowed from Hong Kong's Defiance of a
ban against protest slogans in the
territory
in the face of authority
China is the last major world power to
enforce a zero covid-19 strategy it's
continuing with SNAP block Down's
lengthy quarantines and mass testing to
deal with outbreaks methods abandoned by
other major Nations
record numbers of covid-19 infections
have been recorded for days in a row and
many here are running out of patience
Sonic Gallego Al Jazeera